archeologists are uncovered are
uncovering revealing new pieces of
history from the ancient Roman city of
Pompeii including this skeleton it was
the world's unluckiest man when the
photo went viral this spring it's just
the latest discovery to spotlight one of
the most popular archeological sites in
the world
last year more than 3 million tourists
visited Pompeii which is preserved under
a mountain of volcanic ash in Italy our
Seth Doane travelled there to take a
look this is the forum the main market
place of Pompeii and behind me in the
distance you can see Mount Vesuvius when
that volcano erupted around 2,000 years
ago it covered this place in ash and the
town became a time capsule but today
there is new life here it's the sound of
tools not tourists that fill this part
of Pompeii where the most ambitious
excavation project in a generation is
taking place as the world seen any of
this yet and no know each new discovery
including the richly decorated house of
dolphins has revived this ancient
Italian city massimo asana calls it
Pompey's second life in this moment
started a new life for Pompeii with the
new inhabitants and the inhabitants were
workers archaeologists at saunas field
team of more than 50 are focusing
efforts on a part of this Roman resort
town that had remained buried until less
than a year ago
Francesco mooska lino is one of the
archaeologists is that wood man this is
the political post yes from 2,000 years
ago yes just down the newly excavated
street there cleaning another campaign
sign painted just before the eruption in
79 AD remarkable for its still vibrant
paint you don't find something like this
anywhere on one third of Pompeii is
still covered we are at least a metre
from the original flora they continued
digging out the tons of pumice called
laughingly in Italian that covered this
town in place
from about 10 to 20 feet high sealing it
off for nearly 1500 years here you can
get a sense for how this was all buried
yes because this is the material that
covered
Pompeii for three meters in May Oh sauna
steam announced that find which gained
international attention initially
thought to be an unlucky man killed by a
giant rock as he fled Vesuvius eruption
was so cleared it was a skeleton without
a head a block in the in the place where
we expected so they kept digging they
eventually found the skull in a tunnel
that had been opened during a previous
excavation and it turned out the man had
been asphyxiated the tunnel where the
intact skull was found also revealed the
sometimes sloppy work of previous
generations back then they'd often bore
through walls looking for precious items
today's process is much slower and more
methodical another spouse even sifting
through what had been discarded in
previous excavations you're still
learning as you're going along of course
this is a really an experimentation it
is no manual that's tell you how to
approach so so many complex problems
there using hammers that record wave
velocity to detect how the ancient walls
are holding up now that they're exposed
to the environment and they demonstrated
the laser scanners and drones they use
to record what they find and where they
find it so it can be passed down to
future generations of archaeologists the
timeline is not certain but it's likely
the newly excavated part of Pompeii will
not be open to tourists until at least
sometime next year and it will take
generations for archaeologists to truly
understand what was buried here two
millennia ago for CBS this morning Seth
Doane Pompeii
beautiful to see all of that fascinating
story and there are so many more
discoveries still do you mean yeah third
of it I guess is still still covered